Ils lui ont tout pris
Ses Pokémons
Son fusil
Sa dignité
Et sa carte d'identité pour un petit contrôle
Mais aujourd'hui, il revient plus fort ... que jamais !
Rien ne nous arrêtera !
Tu vois Clément aujourd'hui, on va pas prendre le même chemin,
Aujourd'hui on va prendre le plus gros détour possible
On va passer par la Picardie, c'est vers ici au niveau de cette fenêtre tu peux filmer ?
Voilà, t'es vraiment c*n c'est pas la Picardie, tu vois bien que c'est une fenêtre !
Aujourd'hui on est de retour, plus forts que jamais
Et je peux dire qu'on va capturer un max de Pokémons mon pote !
Laisse passer le Ronflex stp
Donc là comme tu peux le voir sur la carte,
aux alentours il y a ce qu'on appelle un Salamèche
Ce qui est bien avec Pokémon Go c'est que personne a jamais compris le système des pokemons proches
'Fait chaud, hein ?
- 'Fait chaud ouais
Alors ! Salamèche vers où tu es ?
Tu vois j'active la petite boussole
Ça marche vraiment pas ce système
Excusez-moi,
Vous auriez pas vu un Salamèche ?
- Non
Y'a pas de Salamèche ?
Vous l'avez capturer c'est pour ça que vous vous foutez de ma gueule ?
Vous l'avez capturé avant moi ?
Put***! il est dans son sac !
Il est dans son sac on se casse
J'EN AIS MARRE !!!
CETTE RIVALITÉ LÀ !
Là-bas y à un carré d'herbe
Y à un carré d'herbe on va se poser dedans
Elle va aussi au carré d'herbe
Faut pas qu'elle y soit avant nous
COURS !
COURS CLÉMENT !
C'est mon Salamèche !
Ça bouge
Ça bouge, y'a un Pokémon
Stari
Stari est là,
Écartez-vous y'a un Stari
C'est pour votre bien hein
Il est sur le banc put*** !
On allait s’asseoir dessus, Mec !
On l'a, attention,
Il s'est échappé ! Put*** !
C'est à cause d'elles, elles lui ont fait peur !
C'est chiant ça !
Ils veulent me mettre des bâtons dans les roues
Tu comprends ce que j'te dis ?
Moi je veux ce Salamèche et ce Stari
Mais surtout Salamèche
Une vidéo sur Youtube
Sur Pokémon Go
Bah là j'attends, je cherche un Bulbizar y'en a un qu'est pas loin
Mais je le trouve pas
Vous avez une petite indication peut-être ?
Ma fille m'a parlé de ça y'a deux jours
Vous savez dans quelle équipe elle est ?
- Jaune, rouge, bleue ?
- Ah j'vous jure
- Mais si vous savez
Elle est rouge ! REVENEZ ICI !!!
REVENEZ ICI, EST-CE QU'ELLE EST ROUGE ?!
VOUS AVEZ DE LA CHANCE QU'IL Y AIT CETTE BARRIÈRE !
Comment ça s'ouvre Clément ?
Écoute je vais donner une recette de grand-mère,
que mon grand-père m'avait donné
Du coup c'est plutôt une recette de grand-père
Les Salamèches sont très friands des pistaches
Surtout quand t'as ouvert le paquet à l'envers
Un Doduo !
Ça a attiré un putain de doduo !
C'est pas Salamèche mais
Voilà, technique des pistaches
T'as retenu hein ?
Deuxième petite technique de dresseur,
Quand vous voyez un pokestop avec un leurre
Ça veut dire qu'il a des gens autours qui essaient de capturer des pokémons
Et nous on va voler leurs pokémons
Ok on est arrivés, MAIS NON !
Le leurre a disparu !
Le leurre a disparu
Reste pas sur la route con**d
Tu sais pourquoi le leurre a disparu ?
Parce qu'on a pas été assez rapides
Pourquoi on a pas été assez rapides ?
J'arrive plus à parler
Je suis ému y'a plus de leurre, je suis ému !
Moi je pensais rencontrer des dresseurs
Y'a des dresseurs ?
Tout ce qu'ils dressent, c'est des gâteaux
C'est maintenant l'heure de la 3è astuce.
Procurez-vous un véhicule.
Rapide...
Mais pas trop
*Générique de Pokémon*
♫ UN JOUR JE SERAI LE MEILLEUR DRESSEUR ♫
♫ JE ME BATTRAI SANS RÉPIT ♫
Pour avoir de grands Pokémons, il faut employer de grands moyens
♫ JE FERAI TOUT POUR ÊTRE VAINQUEUR ♫
♫ ET GAGNER LES DÉFIS ♫
♫ JE PARCOURAI LA TERRE ENTIÈRE ♫
♫ TRAQUANT AVEC ESPOIR ♫
♫ LES POKÉMONS ET LEURS MYSTÈRES ♫
♫ LE SECRET DE LEUR POUVOIR ♫
♫ POKÉMON, ATTRAPEZ-LES TOUS ♫
♫ C'est notre histoire...  ♫
♫ ENSEMBLE ♫
♫ POUR ♫
♫ LA ♫
♫ VICTOIRE ! ♫
♫ POKÉMON ♫
♫ Rien ne nous arrêtera... ♫
♫ NOTRE AMITIÉ TRIOMPHERA ♫
BULBIZAR ! (x2)
Y'a un Bulbizar
Oh il est level 13
Oh ça pue la merde !
Ça on en veut pas
On va pas le jeter, on va le donner
On va faire un don
wow wow wow
J'ai des fans !
Avec grand plaisir les garçons
Vous me connaissez parce que j'ai les plus grands pokémons de la Terre c'est ça ?
Ça c'est entendu ça ?
C'est entendu ?
Alors que vous savez si y'a un Salamèche ou un truc bien pas loin ?
Y'a des Ponytas ?! Clément on y va !!
Des Ponytas mon gars !
Va te faire enculer !
FUCK ! (x2)
Y'A DES PONYTAS !
Swag
Tu t'appelles Popopum ?
Dans le jeu tu t'appelles comment ?
- AtomiSqwizie
Vient me faire un câlin !
J'me casse !
On a trouvé le parc
Ça sent le Ponyta mon pote !
Oh pop pop
Vous êtes des dresseurs?
Team bleue ?
AAAAAAAAAAH
AAAAAAAAH
Ça joue à Pokémon Go ?
Team bleue ?
WHOOOAA !
Câlin team bleue !
Merci team bleue !
Bah de rien ! ^^
Allez les gars bonne chasse !
Et n'oubliez pas vive la team bleue !
Bon les gars j'ai mytho'
Mais c'est aussi ça Pokémon Go
C'est de l'infiltration
Je suis dans la team rouge
Bonjour messieurs !
Comment allez-vous ?
Ça capture du Pokémon ?
- Un peu ouais
Vous avez payé des taxes là-dessus ?
Parce que ça c'est mon terreterre
C'est ma zone hein
Qu'est-ce que t'as toi montre-moi
Attend je vais regarder plutôt là-bas
ON LUI A VOLÉ SES POKÉMONS !!
C'EST ÇA QU'ON FAIT
C'EST ÇA ! (x2)
Y'a des dresseurs là-bas
On va aller les voir
*kikoos excités en voyant squeezie*
Ça c'est la réputation d'un dresseur ça
Vous avez capturé quoi comme Pokémon ?
Un Ponyta capturé = un Ponyta pour Squeezie
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Je touche un Pokémon sur chaque Pokémon capturé
Sinon j'envoie Ronflex il vous casse les rotules
Ils ont appelé des renforts faut y aller
On est en insécurité
'Faut y aller, 'faut y aller
'Faut y aller, 'faut y aller, 'faut y aller
On est entourés, 'faut y'aller
POUSSEZ-VOUS !
C'EST BON ON PEUT Y ALLER !
J'AI PLUS DE BATTERIE DANS LE KART
ARRÊTEZ !!!
ARRÊTE !
MERDE !
REVIENS-LÀ ! (x3)
Clément, on trouvera cet enculé de Ponyta
Il est par là
Viens viens !
Clément ! Clément !
Clément !
IL EST PAR LÀ ! IL EST LÀ !
Clément ! 657 !
Tu filmes pas ma raie du cul hein ?
Clément tu sais ce qu'il vient de se passer là ?
On a eu Ponyta
Là où ont pissé pas mal de SDF ouais
Aujourd'hui on a appris plein de choses
C'était intense, c'était génial, c'était...
Le meilleure dresseur en action ;)
Attrapez-les tous !
Pour avoir de grands Pokémons il faut employer de grands moyens
Désolé pour ton phone !
*rigole*